I made 20 times more money when I put
all of my effort on the first 5 Seconds
of my videos there's a story of a book
that went out on dating and it tanked
they went back and they changed the
cover of the book and the headline
nothing else inside the book and then it
went on to sell over 10 million copies
just by renaming the book and so the
thing is you're going to put all this
time in delivering an amazing solution
but we have to make sure that the 80% of
your advertising dollar which only goes
towards whether people read the headline
and move on or not is spent well and so
if there's ever a most important step
it's this one which is how you name it
and how you package it